diamond cuts that's the focus of
tonight's
angle the snow and ice at Davos hasn't
completely frozen out all common sense
JP Morgan's Chief Jamie Diamond is
slowly thawing to the idea that business
should not be taking sides against
hardworking Americans I think we should
stop insulting the other side including
magga a lot of people voting for
president Trump not because they believe
in his family values but they look at
some of the things he
did he grew the economy he was right
about NATO they spend more money he was
right about all of that he was right
that these regulations don't cause
positive output now Diamond's a typical
wall streer he's a liberal on social
issues but he's moderate on fiscal
issues but he's no dummy he sees what
we've been warning about for so many
years that if the Democrats stay joined
to the hard left they're eventually
going to lose influence and credibility
and Lord knows if you want to avoid what
happened at Disney after its fight with
conservatives you shouldn't want to
throw into the likes of these people I
have thought an awful lot about blowing
up the White House of course I want to
punch him in the face right he's an
he is so
dangerous because Trump speaks to the
middle class right the working class
they consider
him well to be an enemy and then the
working class considers attacks on Trump
really to be attacks on them and their
way of life and I think the Democrats
should be a little more thoughtful when
they talk about mag say why not not like
and then not don't act like every
attribute of trump is an attribute of
them it's just not
true correct and likewise likewise it's
a mistake for all the Business Leaders
to weigh in on the side of the far-left
on social and Ral IAL issues as well now
nothing was more embarrassing than when
CEO after CEO came out to pronounce on
George Floyd's death as if he were
Martin Luther King
Jr companies like ours must speak up as
allies to the black lives matter
Movement we were on record back in 2016
in supporting a black lives matter
Business Leaders cannot remain silent on
important issues whether it's racial
Equity G
Equity now the country is not
systemically racist but many of them say
it is and instituting Dei policies that
discriminate against non-minorities that
is systemically racist and that's what
they do but the backlash is building
against the hyper politicization of
business and it's not going to end well
for these corporate Titans who thought
that their trans flag pins and Net Zero
pledges was going to save them you see
the left is Never Satisfied if you give
them an inch they will take a mile and a
pound of Flesh and eventually you're
going to get run over
completely they accuse Trump of being a
dictator but they're the stalinists they
require complete loyalty or
else just ask Elon Musk now the left
once adored him but now he's one of
their top enemies just because he's
actually in favor a free speech think
about that and if top execs think their
cooperation with the left helps kind of
create a cool Factor they should think
about that again World economic
attendees paid tens of thousands of
dollars hoping to hobnob with Bono and
zalinski but instead they heard what
passes as an enlightened
presentation
but
seriously the business Community has
enough trouble on its hands without
getting dragged down further by the
neist on the left Walter Russell me
writing in the Wall Street Journal
perfectly captured how the global Elites
have humiliated themselves by creating a
mess of things and then insulting the
working class writing that the real
Scandal of Davos isn't that it's taking
over the world it's that it's failing
why would voters expect an expert class
that was so wrong for so long about
Russia China Iran and Co to know how to
cope with a challenge as difficult and
multifaceted as the energy
transition and this is my favorite part
the emperor has no close that's the Cry
of populace everywhere to render this
message ineffective Davos man doesn't
need image consultants and
disinformation Specialists he needs to
get
dressed now I've been giving a lot of
unsolicited advice this week that's
gotten me in some trouble and offended
some people but why am I going to stop
now so my strong suggestion to
suggestion to the business Community is
that your foolish alliance with the hard
left has got to end start trying to
appeal more to just regular people
regular Americans and in return populist
conservative leaders are going to give
you sound tax and Regulatory policies
sensible judges on the courts and
they'll also protect you from the
crazies on the farle now you've heard
president Trump who says he's G to you
know he's going to work with Democrats
not against them and he wants to clean
up the cities by cracking down on crime
and stopping the influx of migrants that
none of us can
absorb so someone like Jamie Diamond and
his firm JP Morgan and frankly most
American CEOs would benefit enormously
from these policies and he's smart
enough to know that more prosperity and
freedom creates more Innovation and
exchange for all of this these business
Big Wigs have to give the regular people
something you have to be flexible on
some issues you have to be flexible on
decoupling from China on fighting maybe
fewer Wars stronger border enforcement
ending Dei and other woke policies that
discriminate on the basis of race and
conflict with parental
rights the evidence is
overwhelming that the alliance between
the business community and the left has
been a really really bad fit all it's
done is fuel pointless controversies and
offend patriotic hardworking
Americans so the Davos Divas need to
wake up enough to realize that their
relationship with the far-left is toxic
it's time to break it off and it's time
to get back to business and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else